they're right here
they just went in this building enemy
just went into this building I need them
to say that nobody are there friendly
forces in here no problem okay that's
all I'm asking man this is what war
looks like when you're a captain in the
US Army when you're less than a thousand
yards from the frontlines
I'm asking them to confirm or deny if
that's them is this is it - or friendly
that's a lot when you're working
alongside Iraqi Jews clear proof
generally when making the final calls
that are the difference between who
lives and who dies
they have to see the objective so they
still have about three kilometers to get
to the Tigris so this is one victory for
today but there's there's weeks of
fighting what officially Baylor and the
Americans are here only to advise and
assist but the strikes they're ordering
will come from the american-led
coalition planes in the sky Sadie - -
right there yeah she and Laura are they
were doing the tape
captain Baylor does this all day trying
to make sure what he sees on his screens
is right ordering a strike will kill an
Isis fighter and not an Iraqi soldier or
civilian hey Dan just fear si we've got
two zero zero dynamic on a moto and
we've got general only here one doesn't
strike it I think go a long way if we
could get these guys to approve rapidly
yeah they're traveling straight towards
friendlies we got to start working the
strike
let's go
[Music]